[Music]
i'm a big fan of the wnba you think
about the nba in its 25th year
was not where it is now it's in year 75
right so it's so much
opportunity and so much growth um that's
coming but what i really love about the
w is the activism i just love the way
that the w stands together you know
locked arms it's not one person it's a
whole lead and every time something
social
something that hits home
something that's important to talk about
that we need voices it's the w who steps
up first yeah that's one of the things i
love most about it is like
i feel like everyone in there is so
empowered to just like say whatever they
think
and i think it's like the demographic
that we have too it's like predominantly
like gay black women in the league and
so that's like a minority and so we feel
like now we have a platform where we
could talk about these things and then
we see other things like other
injustices happening and
you know maybe we knew how that felt so
we want to speak out against that or i
just feel like they're so fearless and
like as a group we're so powerful that
we know like the platform that we have
now and so whenever we see something
that we don't think is right like we
feel like not only should we do it but
it's kind of like on our shoulders to be
able to speak out i think one of the
things about the wnba and their social
activism it it was never a one and done
for them they've been doing it for well
over a decade probably for the full 25
years
i'm kathy engelbert the commissioner of
the wnba
i think the events of 2020 where we had
the entire league in one place in the
wnba bubble in florida at img academy
and i think what happened then is
now millions know that the wnba players
have such strong social justice stances
and i think it's really important that
people know what they stand for and
they've been such leaders in this area
as the nba we look to the w first
and see what they're doing more times
than not they speak on uh you know
things that are going on in the world
before we do you know what i'm saying i
think we kind of follow their lead to a
point so i think that's the best part
about the w is how they're so ahead of
everything and and just the support that
you know obviously they give us and we
give back i feel like it can it can't
even get better like the relationship
between uh the w and the nba everybody
come together and voice their opinion
about things that's that's going on in
the world i feel like um not last year
2020 that was like we kind of want to
stand in solidarity to you guys when you
stepped out of the game like we want
that too we want to be like with you
guys and making sure that we're standing
as like a united front for sure coming
off that playoffs
it was incredible if you love basketball
to be able to watch that playoffs the
wnba playoffs was amazing how can you
guys assist so how can we all help the
popularity continue to grow us as the
nba guys going to their games showing
love support
i see that a lot more we just awarded
the inaugural kobe and gigi bryant wnba
advocacy award at the nba all-star game
this year to chris paul who's been a
huge advocate not only for youth sports
uh but also of the wnba they're players
it's those kind of advocates like kobe
bryant was for the women's game that we
need to expand upon and i think nba
players have done that i've never seen
such great support there's a reason why
the wnba has been the only women's
professional sport to last 25 years and
that's double any other women's
professional league in america think
about that it's because we share the mba
brand i just bought my first wnba jersey
the other day so uh you know wear that
in the tunnel when you know as the
season gets closer i'd like the you know
kind of the orange hoodie thing they did
a couple years ago i thought that was
like super cool to kind of build
momentum towards your guys's season but
i think at the same time like we were
talking about earlier like you were
talking about like controversy helps too
you know what i'm saying like the more
conversations we have about about the
league like good or bad like it it does
help and it brings attention and there's
so much great basketball played that you
know the more people that actually sit
down and watch a game they'll fall in
love with it you guys just got a 75
million dollar you know capital raise
yep can you
tell us about it what is that what what
do that money go how does that help the
league grow i mean i honestly don't know
where the like i don't know how it's
distributed the 75 million capital raise
was really a watershed moment for
women's professional sports and i think
once again the wnba we're leading around
how to deploy that capital to grow the
game both the youth side of the game as
well as the professional side of the
game and everything in between and so
we're going to make it easier to be a
fan we're going to uh you know look at a
five-year business transformation to you
know change our digital products meet
our fans where they are they're very
digital they want uh content they want
year-round content we're also looking at
globalizing the game we're looking at
innovation like nfts and sports betting
and espn just launched the first ever
wnba fantasy game for instance so how do
you draw in that fan keep that fan get
them to come to arenas get them to watch
on our very different platforms uh and
we're just continuing looking at optical
tracking and wearables and lots of
different innovative things which before
raising this capital we didn't have the
ability to do
you have to spend money to make money
and that's always people's arguments
like if you want people to come you have
to promote revenue like you have to put
in money to something to for it to grow
does that make you excited about where
the future of the game is going and you
know you can see like okay now we have
people believing in us a little bit more
yeah it's really exciting and we have
some great partners like we they call
each other um change makers because
they're trying to like make a difference
in women's sports and in our league so
it's awesome to see that because like
you guys were talking it's funny about
the silas you're like do you care what
the price tag is and you're like nah i
got that new contract i don't care i'm
like i'm still like budgeting on my
contract
so it's awesome like like i said our new
ca was really good like the money's gone
up and it's better than what it used to
be but it's like nowhere near what we
feel like we deserve or where we want it
to be the steps the wnba is making
around pay is very multi-dimensional so
the owners and the league stepped up in
the last collective bargaining agreement
to triple the pay of the top players to
give a lot of other off-season
capabilities in order to grow not only
their on-court skills but their
off-the-court skills um the average
tenure of a wnba player any professional
athlete is not that long and they need
to you know be
gaining skills while they're still
playing in order to see what they're
going to do post their playing career so
um we've got internships we've opened up
coaching opportunities not only in the
wnba but the nba and the g league and
you know there's some you know christy
tolliver's a great example of that you
know coaching for dallas this season in
the off season
we also have league marketing
opportunities and team marketing
opportunities so players what we're
doing over the course of this collective
bargaining cycle is giving players a lot
more opportunities to earn more money we
introduced a new special competition
during the 2021 season this year will be
the second um called the commissioner's
cup where just the winner of that will
get 30 000 each player so more
opportunities for players to make more
money in order to um you know have our
players really prioritize the wnba as
their season and their job
in the nba we talked about how social
media versus mainstream media
how does it help or affect i feel like
in the wnba you guys haven't had a lot
of mainstream media but the social
component has been
has been pretty big right whether it's
activism whether it's uh the walks
through the tunnels i love watching the
women when they come in with they swag
um how how do you think the social you
know component of you know of the world
has really helped the wnba it's helped
us a lot especially because like one of
the biggest problems is we're not on tv
you know like when people watch us they
become fans like it's good basketball
it's just it's not accessible no one
wants to go on twitter or facebook to
like search for a game that we only get
true fans doing that so if there was
like a game um five for the wnba
championship it wasn't going to be on
espn 1. like that's crazy so we have to
like you guys supporting us is a huge
part of it and it's awesome we also need
the stuff like we have to be able to be
on tv i want to ask a question
um
like people always talk about like
more like that they think the w should
have like more teams i played in
sacramento and like the monarchs like
they got it all all hung up right and
like they they always talk about like
the legends of the monarchs how good
they were and things like that like but
and i'll say like the other side of the
argument like if there's more teams and
that's like more money that's got to go
and then what happens to the salaries
and things like that so like what's your
take on that we definitely need more
teams like there's just too much talent
to accommodate 144 people yeah like you
have really good people not making
rosters and the people who are on the
rosters like you're not getting playing
time because the talent is like so
concentrated you have like rookies who
aren't playing for years because they're
just behind good players we're being
very thoughtful about expansion i think
it is on the horizon but we need to have
our finances in a better place in the
economic model so that new owners who
start up a team in a new city can thrive
when they come in when you do only have
12 teams 144 players there's a lot of
players who get drafted in the second
and third round of our wnba draft who
may not make a team
and nafis is right about thinking about
why there's so much talent out there
that doesn't make a wnba team and we've
got to expand those opportunities which
we're in the process of thinking through
when the wnba is in year 50
and they're celebrating their 50th year
the nba celebrating his 100th year but
what do you want the wnba to be what's
the vision what's the goal in 25 years
16 million dollars i don't see a million
dollars yeah there you go million dollar
contract
and i want to get on twitter and
see people debating about you know
whoever is next up like
they better than diana you know
you know who's gonna be the michael
jordan where they're always coming
exactly that's what i want to see you
know what i'm saying so what i'd like
the wnba to look like in 25 years at our
50th anniversary is it really needs to
be thriving as a
really legitimized sports media and
entertainment property where the players
are household names where fans are
consuming our content in whatever way in
25 years uh consumers are consuming
content whether that's around a.i
augmented reality vr
you know all of the technologies that
are emerging today and that we're a
global sport the future of the game is
bright you see the popularity of the
sport at the ncaa level you know girls
between eight and 18 there's five to six
million girls playing basketball in
america today so i mean it's a really
positive sign for the future of the
sport and um i think we will be able to
go from survive to thrive over the next
25 years i feel like talent that's
coming in is just it's just basketball
just keep getting better over and over
right yeah year after year we keep
talking about like the more accessible
the game is on on tv and obviously
they're doing things on social media but
the more accessible the game is when
people watch they become fans like no
doubt about that
you